FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I HADTO PRESENT A BILL --
DOWNSTAIRS ON THE FIRST FLOOR
BUT I'M HERE FOR THE DURATION
NOW AND IN WHAT MIGHT BE A
HISTORIC FIRST WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
THE MEETING BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM.
LET'S TAKE ROLE [inaudible]
BLOOM.
HERE FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS.
REVERSE.
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE WILL -- MOVED
TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND I
WANT -- TO CLARIFY THAT.
OF FOR A ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF VOTE ONLY ISSUE --
ELEVEN AND I'LL DISCUSS ELEVEN
IN A MOMENT -- WE ARE APPROVING
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
ON THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT STAFF RECOMMENDATION -- ON
VOTE ONLY ISSUE ELEVEN WE'RE
GOING TO POSTPONE ACTION ON THAT
ITEM -- AND DISPENSE WITH THAT
AT A FUTURE HEARING SO I ISSUE
ELEVEN ON THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDARS PAUL [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
DO WE HAVE THE BUT ON THE JUST --
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEMS.
OF ONE THROUGH TWENTY THREE ON
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF AS I MENTIONED
ISSUE ELEVEN OTHER HAS BEEN
PULLED.
MOVED AND SECONDED.
BLOOM I FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS.
REVERSE.
GREAT WILL TAKE ADD ONS ON THAT
TO FURTHER ON IN THE MEETING GOT
THAT TAKES US. TO OUR ITEMS TO
BE HEARD WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH
ISSUE -- ISSUES ONE THROUGH --
THREE YOU MAY RECALL THAT WE HAD
THIS ITEM ON OUR LAST AGENDA THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND AS THE DIRECTOR WAS NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE ALONG WITH STAFF
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY THEY WERE --
ATTENDING THE FUNERAL FOR UP A
RETIRED REGIONAL CHIEF STAND
CRACK -- CRAIG AND I WANT TO
AGAIN OFFER -- THE COMMITTEES
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S CONDOLENCES
TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THE LOSS OF
FOR A SOMEONE WHO I UNDERSTAND
WAS A VERY VALUED.
MEMBER OF THE TEAM.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
YEAH.
STAND WAS A BIG LOSS FOR US HE'D
BEEN RETIRED FOR SEVERAL YEARS
BUT HE HE KIND OF CAME BACK AND
HELPED US IN SOME DIFFICULT
TIMES OUT OF RETIREMENT SOME
THANK YOU.
FOR RECOGNIZING HIM OF COURSE --
FOR THIS MORNING -- WE WE HAVE --
THAT THE FIRST ITEM OF ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE CONSERVE A
BEIJING CAM -- REPLACEMENT
KITCHEN -- IS A REQUEST FOR A
FIVE POINT -- THREE TWO EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND --
TO FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE
COSTS OF REPLACING THE KITCHEN
AND DINING FACILITY AT THE CAMP.
IN TO HIM A COUNTY -- THIS CAMP
IS A HUNDRED A MEMBER CAMP --
AND SERVICES -- EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF OF FOR SR RAY.
A DOING FUELS RELATED PROJECTS
AND WORKING -- ON TREE MORTALITY
ISSUES -- IT WAS BUILT IN --
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THE CAMP'S
KITCHEN AND DINING FACILITY WAS
DESTROYED IN A FIRE IN JULY OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY -- IT WAS A
COMPLETE LOSS -- IN THE INTERIM --
IMMEDIATELY AFTERWARDS IN ORDER
TO KEEP THE CAMP OPEN AND
WORKING WE UTILIZED OUR MOBILE
KITCHEN UNIT THE ON SITE.
AND TENTS -- AND THAT HAS BEEN
IN IMPACTS TO THE ABILITIES OF
THE CAMP -- TO HOUSE ADDITIONAL
CREWS AND INMATES WERE -- THAT
ARE ON THOSE CREWS WHEN WE HAVE
A LARGE -- FIRES IN THE AREA OR
WE'RE TRYING TO STAGE RESOURCES --
AT THAT CAMP -- SO THAT THAT
FACILITY HAS BEEN -- IMPACTED IN
THAT WAY -- WE HAVE MOVED THE
FEEDING -- NOW AND FACILITY
KITCHEN FACILITIES TO SOME OF
THE OTHER -- BUILDINGS AND ARE
MAKING IT MAKING DO -- BUT IT IS
NOT SUFFICIENT TO KEEP THE CAMP
RUNNING AS WE EED -- TO ON A
LONG TERM BASIS.
THE THIS FUNDING WILL HELP US
GET BACK TO A NORMAL OPERATION
AND BE ABLE TO SERVICE ALL OF
THE FUELS READ IT LATER PROJECT
WORK -- IN TO HIM A COUNTY AND
BEYOND AND THEN THE FIRE MISSION
AS WELL.
AS THE TREE MORTALITY REMOVAL
THE NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
THAT'S WHAT WE GOT.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANY -- LA --
REPORT SELECT SERVICE JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND SO YOU ARE
HEARD A REQUEST RELATED TO THIS
PROJECT I AM ALREADY EARLIER
THIS YEAR SO IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
ON THE BUDGET INCLUDED A LITTLE
OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THAT
YOU SHE KITCHEN PROJECT --
WITHIN THAT THREE OR FOUR MONTHS
SINCE THEN -- CAL FIRE HAS
LEARNED OTHER PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
COST INCREASE ON THAT CHIP
RELEASE THAT IS BASED ON THE
CHANGE IN THE SCOPE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT.
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY ABOUT
DOUBLING THE CONSTRUCTION COST
FROM WHAT YOU HEARD JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO -- THAT
TYPICALLY WHEN AT APARTMENT WELL
BE FACED WITH A CHANGE IN SCOPE
OR SOMETHING VERY UNEXPECTED
ESPECIALLY OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
AND THEY WILL OFTEN GO BACK AND
LOOK FOR WAYS TO MITIGATE THOSE
COSTS AND ENSURE THAT THE
KALEIDOSCOPE CHANGES REALLY
FULLY NECESSARY.
AND AND LOOK FOR MAYBE OTHER
VALUE ENGINEERING OR THINGS TO
TO BRING THE COST DOWN BEFORE
THEY COME FORWARD.
GIVEN THE TIMING OF WHEN CAL
FIRE AT LEARNED ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE RESULTED IN THIS
REQUEST.
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO
GO THROUGH AND DO THAT TYPE OF
BACK AND FORTH I'M ON THE
PROJECT TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE
COST INCREASE.
I AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING AT
THAT FUNDING AND IN JANUARY AND
THE APRIL INCREASE FOR THE
PROJECT.
BY ADDING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE -- TO ONLY
ALLOW CAL FIRE TO ACCESS THIS
PIECE OF THE FUNDING -- AFTER
THEY HAVE COMPLETED THAT WORK OF
GOING BACK AND LOOKING AT AND
HOW THEY CAN POTENTIALLY
MITIGATE THE COST INCREASE ON
THAT I KNOW THAT SOMETHING TO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON AND THEY
JUST HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME GIVEN
THE TIMING OF WHEN THEY LEARNED
ABOUT.
THE COST INCREASE SO FOR EXAMPLE
AND THE MAJORITY OF THIS COST
INCREASES RELATED TO A VERY
LARGE WATER TANK.
THAT WILL HAVE TO HE ADDED TO
THE PROJECT ON AND SO THE SIZE
OF THAT WATER TANK IS SOMEONE IN
QUESTION BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE AT THIS CAMP
THERE IS A FIRE TRUCK AND THAT'S
ON SITE AND A FIRE STATION THAT
IS NEARBY.
AND SO AS THEY TAKE THOSE THINGS
INTO CONSIDERATION THAT COULD
HELP OFFSET SOME OF THAT THE
SCOPE CHANGE THAT IS INCLUDED
HERE AND THIS IS SORT OF THE
FULL MAGNITUDE OF IT.
AND SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS TO
REALLY TRY TO GET THE COST BACK
DOWN WE WOULD RECOMMEND ADDING
THAT PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU DOES -- DEPARTMENT
FANS HAVE ANY COMMENTS ENTER
SHARP FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT THAT
THE STANDARD CAPITAL A PROCESS
IS AS WE GO THROUGH.
THE WORKING DRAWINGS AND DESIGN
IF WE DO FIND EFFICIENCIES --
THOSE FUNDS FOR THE CAPITAL
PROJECT TO REVERT BACK TO THE
FINE FOR WHICH THEY WERE
ORIGINATED IN WE WOULD COMMIT TO
DOING THAT AB IF WE FOUND
EFFICIENCIES TO REVERT.
THE FUNDS BACK THAT IS STANDARD
PRACTICE.
HOWEVER -- I DID WANT TO SAY YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN IN CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH LA -- AND IF
IT'S A LEGISLATORS LEGISLATIVE
PURVIEW TO ADD BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE I THINK THAT WE COULD
WORK ON SOMETHING SO -- IT'S NOT
A PREFERENCE BUT I THINK WE
COULD WORK ON SOMETHING IF
NECESSARY -- OKAY.
THE QUESTIONS SIR COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM.
PLEASE THIS RACE.
SO IT IS I UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE
DO REQUEST PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THEN -- THE THE MINISTRATION AND
PUBLIC FINANCE IN LA -- WOULD
WORK ON THE LANGUAGE.
YES I I THINK THAT'S ACCEPTABLE
PER CONVERSATIONS I THINK WE
COULD WORK ON SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T HAMPER THE PROJECT IF
THE LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE FELT
THAT WAS NECESSARY WONDERFUL
THANK YOU.
IF I COULD SUMMARIZE LA --
THINKS WE SHOULD DO PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS WE'RE GONNA DO THAT ANYWAY
IT'S REALLY NOT NECESSARY BUT WE
COULD DO IT -- I THINK MY
PREFERENCE -- IS ALWAYS TO HAVE
SOME YOU KNOW BELTS AND
SUSPENDERS.
BUILT INTO THE PROCESS -- AND I
THINK EVERYBODY'S MORE LESS ON
THE SAME PAGE I PREFER TO HAVE
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE HI
THERE -- BUT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
HURT -- SO DO WE NEED -- TO CAN
WE CAN WE APPROVE IT.
TO THIS BUDGET WITH PROVISIONAL.
OKAY -- SO WHEN WE GET TO
MOTIONS -- I THINK.
I WILL DO PUBLIC COMMENT --
AFTER ISSUE THREE AND THEN WE'LL
JUST TO A SERIES OF WELL TO BE
TO MOTIONS BECAUSE NUMBER THREE
IS -- IS A HOLD OPEN.
HI BUT WILL -- ASK FOR THAT --
WITH THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
[inaudible]
ISSUE.
TWO VERY GOOD.
TWO CALPERS REQUESTING SEVEN
POINT THREE FOUR THREE MILLION.
DOLLARS AND RELEASED REVENUE IN
LEASE REVENUE BONDS -- FOR
ADDITIONAL -- COSTS FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF A CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING RELATED TO THE SAN
MATTEO SANTA CRUZ -- AUTO SHOP --
AND THAT -- CONSTRUCTION PHASE
COST IT WAS UNFORTUNATELY --
ANOTHER ONE OF THESE -- AS WE
LOOKED AT IT FURTHER -- AND THE
AT AND AND AND ANALYZED THE
COSTS GOING FORWARD -- THE
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE --
DUE -- TO THE AREA OF WHICH THIS
IS IS HAPPENING IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY -- CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE
MORE THAN WHEN THIS WAS FIRST
SCOPED -- THE SOME OF THE ITEMS
THAT ARE ATTACHED TO THIS
INCLUDING THE FIRE SYSTEM --
WATER -- TANK -- ARE ALSO
INCREASING IN COSTS.
THE MATERIALS -- AS THIS WAS
SCOPE A LONG TIME BACK -- AND
THE ANTICIPATED COST OF THOSE
HAVE INCREASED AS WELL AS THE
CONSTRUCTION CONTINGENCY THAT'S
ATTACHED TO ALL OF THAT.
AND IN CONCLUSION THAT'S ISSUE.
TWO THANK YOU MISS PETERS
SENDING COMMENTS.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ONE BUT
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THIS IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASE --
FROM WHAT THE PROJECT WAS
ESTIMATED TO BE WHEN IT WENT OUT
TO BED AND THEN THE BIDS COMING
BACK ON THE PROJECT ALL OF THEM.
ON THE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THE
LOWEST ONE WAS AND IT'S ABOUT
SIXTY SEVEN CLOSE 270% ABOVE
WHAT THE ESTIMATE WISE AND SO
FOR US AND THERE'S THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT AT THIS POINT GIVEN
THE STAGE THE PROJECT IS THEN.
AND THAT WE THINK YOU CAN REALLY
DO ON THIS PROJECT SHORT OF YOU
KNOW MAYBE DECIDING TO NOT GO
FORWARD WITH IT WHICH WERE NOT
RECOMMENDING BUT IT DOES RAISE
SOME GOOD OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
AND ISSUES FOR YOU IN TERMS OF
HOW CAL FIRE IS WORKING.
WITH THE D. G. S. ON MANAGING
ITS PROJECTS -- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT PART OF
THE GENESIS FOR THIS ISSUE IS
THAT TIME CAL FIRE INDEED YES
HAD TAKEN THE PLANS FROM ANOTHER
SIMILAR PROJECT.
AND TAKE IN THE ESTIMATE FROM
THAT PROJECT AND DECIDED OKAY
WE'RE GONNA JUST REUSE THOSE
SAME PLANS AND THEY RE USE THAT
SAME ESTIMATE AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
PERHAPS THAT ESTIMATE.
THE ORIGINAL ONE THAT THEY USED
MAYBE HAD SOME ISSUES WITH IT
AND THAT PROJECT HAD HAD SOME
COST INCREASES AND SO.
SEEMS LIKE THERE MIGHT NOT BE
THAT SYSTEMS IN PLACE INTERNALLY
AND HOW GOING BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN CAO FIRING TGS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ESTIMATES THAT
THEY'RE USING ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE TRYING TO TAKE THE
PLANTS FROM ANOTHER PROJECT.
HAVE BEEN FULLY UPDATED TO
ACCOUNT FOR OTHER CHANGES OR TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT MAYBE
THAT ORIGINAL ESTIMATE HAD SOME
ISSUES WITH THE IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND SO WE THINK IT JUST
RAISES SOME OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS.
I'M NOW IN IN THE FUTURE ABOUT
HOW THESE PROJECTS ARE BEING
MANAGING HOW THE ESTIMATES ARE
BEING DEVELOPED.
ON BETWEEN HOW FIRE AND TGS SO --
DOES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ONE
OF REFLECT ON ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
GET ME UNDER SHARPER FINANCE --
I JUST WANNA SAY WE ARE ON THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY SIDE AND YOUR
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD SEVERAL
ISSUES TO WHERE WE ARE FINDING
COST INCREASES WITH MATERIALS
AND LABOR -- IT'S IN NATURE OF
HAVING A GOOD ECONOMY WHICH IS
GOOD AND IN ONE WAY BUT NOT SO
GOOD.
FOR áP COSTS.
SO -- WE DEFINITELY HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT PROJECTS AND IT MAY I
AM WE'LL BE TALKING INTERNALLY
ABOUT SOME STRATEGIES WE WANT TO
DO EVEN GOING INTO NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET AS TO WHETHER WE WANT TO
DO COST UPDATES -- ON A GRAND
SCALE FOR SOME OF OUR OLDER
PROJECTS WE GET A LOT OF
EFFICIENCIES WHEN WE USE DESIGNS
FOR PROJECTS EXPRESSLY WHEN
THEY'RE ALMOST SIMILAR YOU KNOW
WE CAN SAVE A LOT OF MONEY BUT
WEAR THAT.
AND IT DOES THE THE PITFALL IS
FOR THINGS THAT WE CAN'T REALLY
ACCOUNT FOR AND THAT'S THE
ECONOMY AND MATERIALS SO WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT -- DOING SOME
DEEPER ANALYSIS INTO THAT AND
WHETHER WILL -- UPDATE PROJECTS
ON A LARGER SCALE IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING I'LL BE
LOOKING OUT OF MY AREA.
BUT I I THINK FOR THIS PROJECT
THERE'S WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD.
THE DIRECTOR PORTER YOUR KIND OF
TAKING A FRESH LOOK AT THIS
BECAUSE ALL THIS PROCEEDED -- TO
YOUR TO YOUR TIME IS TO AS
DIRECTOR -- DO YOU SEE ANY
PLACES -- WHERE YOU WOULD DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY OR THERE'S
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE -- FROM
THE PROCESS HERE -- YES IN ON
SCOPE I AM I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU A BRIDGE A MINUTE TAKE
A BRIDGE -- AND INTRODUCE --
MIKE DUGGAN WHO'S BEEN BEFORE
YOU BEFORE -- THESE ARE --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF TECH SERVICES
AND HE'S ACTUALLY GONNA PROVIDES
SOME OF THAT BACKGROUND THANK
YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- THE ESTIMATE THAT --
THE LA WOULD MENTION WAS AN AUTO
SHOP THAT WAS JUST COMPLETED IN
DECEMBER -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN VERY
SIMILAR IN IN FUNCTION AND
ACTUAL FOOTPRINTS SO -- THAT
PROJECT HAD OVER A BIT QUITE A
BIT -- AS FAR AS OUR EFFORTS IN
THE FUTURE -- DID YES DID.
LET US KNOW THAT THEY THOUGHT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE A BUDGET
DEFICIT ON THIS FLIGHT. TO THIS
SCALE WE DID NOT KNOW SO THIS
WAS -- I'D BIG AYE OPENER IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH FINANCE IN THE
LA L. -- HAVE BRIGHT TO REALLY
TO THE FOREFRONT OF THAT WE NEED
TO DO THIS WORK GOES TO BED AND
BE MUCH MORE AWARE WHAT WE'RE
FACING -- GOING FORWARD I THINK
OF LOOKING AT IT.
WE TRY TO DO OUR BEST AS FAR AS
LOOKING THAT ARE THERE ARE OTHER
ESTIMATED IN WITH THAT PROJECT
ENDED UP AT AT ITS CLOSE.
AND ROUGHLY HOW MUCH IT HAD GONE
OVER FROM THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATE --
I THINK THE ITEMS THAT WE DIDN'T
TAKE INTO SERIOUS ACCOUNT WAS
THE LOCATION.
OF BEDLAM IN CAMP WHERE THIS
AUTO SHOPS GOING WHICH IS AN
NARROW ROAD SO -- TRANSPORTATION
MATERIALS -- WAS BASICALLY
DOUBLED -- THAT WAS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT IN THE ESTIMATE SO I
THINK IT'S FROM TALKING I
PRIMARILY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WANNA HAVE A SIT DOWN
WITH TGS BEFORE THESE GO TO BED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT OUR ALL
REVENUES COVERED.
QUITE HONESTLY Là BARRISTAN
THIS.
ONE OKAY WELL -- AS LONG AS ALL
THAT -- EMBARRASSMENT OR
WHATEVER A ONE WANTS TO CALL IT --
IS CHANNELED INTO A POSITIVE
PLACE THEN WILL END UP IN A GOOD
PLACE IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS
PROJECT WAS DESTINED TO COST.
MORE THAN IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PROJECTED -- FOR IT'S NOT A COST
OVERRUN IN THE SENSE THAT -- YOU
KNOW TRADITIONALLY WEAK -- WOULD
REALLY HAVE CONCERNS
STRUCTURALLY -- ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BUT IT IT IT IT.
ALSO LIKE THE THE TROUBLING PART
OF IT IS IT SOUNDS LIKE.
THERE WERE -- THERE WAS AN
ASSUMPTION THAT BECAUSE AN AUTO
SHOP COSTS X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
IN ONE PLACE IT'LL COST ABOUT
THE SAME THING IN ANOTHER PLACE
AND TAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A
VERY.
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ANALYZE
PROJECTS.
MR FUNG HAS A QUESTION.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION -- FOR
FIDELIO.
IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT.
AND THE ANALYSIS YOU'VE DONE FOR
OTHER AGENCIES IS THIS AN
ANOMALY OR DO YOU DO DO YOU SEE
A PATTERN OF OF OF CONCERNED
WITH D. G. S. N..
AND THE THE PLANNING AND THAT
AND THE COST ESTIMATES I AM I
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AND OUR STAFF
WHO WORKS ON TGS GET BACK TO YOU
I'M NOT.
AWARE I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS DRIVING SOME OF THE
CONCERN IS THAT YOU IN IN TERMS
OF THE APRIL REQUEST THAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU THAT YOU HAD TO
PROJECTS WITH REALLY SIGNIFICANT
COST INCREASES.
WE LOOKED INTO IT WAS FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS -- YOU KNOW
ONE THE THE ISSUE PROJECT THAT
YOU HEARD ALREADY -- IS MORE OF
A SCOPE CHANGE THIS ONE IS MORE
OF I THINK JUST ENSURING THAT
THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION AND
PROCESS IN PLACE. TO WEAR THEIR
ESTIMATES ARE AND YOU KNOW OUR
MORE REASONABLE IT'S IT'S YOU
KNOW IN THIS CASE IT WENT SO FAR
OVER THAT THEY WERE NOT.
ABLE TO OVER THE PROJECT AND GO
FORWARD AS PLANNED -- BUT WE CAN
GET BACK TO YOU IF THERE'S OTHER
MORE BROAD CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
I AND I I WOULD SAY IF THERE ARE
BROAD CONCERNS IF THE IF IF
THERE AREN'T THAN JUST REPORT
BACK TO US IF THERE ARE THAN WE
SHOULD CONSIDER -- ADDRESSING
THAT PUBLICLY -- IN A IN A IN A
FUTURE HEARING.
A BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE AN
INDICATION THAT THERE'S MORE
ENDEMIC ISSUES THAT THAT NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED.
SORRY DIDN'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
BUT PLEASE JUST A SCORES ARE --
OUR INTERACTION WITH THE G. AS
THIS WAS AN ANOMALY -- ALSO
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR OUR
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD WE DON'T
WANT.
TO COME BACK TO YOU IN THE SAME
LIGHT.
APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I EXPECT
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR BACK AND CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE ARE BACK.
THANK YOU FOR THE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS -- IF THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WHEN WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE
WHICH THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
WHICH THE RECOMMENDATIONS HOLD
OPEN AND THEN WE'LL TAKE.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
I THANK JUDY ONE NUMBER.
THREE SO AGAIN TOM PORTER -- AND
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE A WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RECOVERY -- B. C. P. -- THIS
THIS IS A ADDITIONAL REQUEST OF
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GREENHOUSE --
REDUCTION FUNDS -- FOR TWO
ADDITIONAL -- POSITIONS -- THAT
WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS SENATE
BILL -- NINE OH ONE AND THAT
SPECIFICALLY IS -- RELATED TO
THE WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
BY -- THE UTILITY COMPANIES.
AND FURTHER.
TO THE REASON IT'S AN ADDITION
IS -- THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE DECISION IN JANUARY OF OF
THIS YEAR -- TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HAS CLARIFIED -- SOME
OF THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
UTILITIES NEED -- TO PLACE IN
THESE -- DOCUMENTS AND PLANS --
THAT INCREASE THE WORKLOAD --
AND STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT THAT -- THE DEPARTMENT WILL
HAVE UNDER UNDER THAT -- NINE A
ONE IMPLEMENTATION -- THIS WILL
HELP -- WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
PIECE OF HEY -- INSURING THAT
THESE PLANS ARE IN FACT MOVING
TOWARD A MITIGATING -- THE RISKS
THAT THAT UTILITIES -- ARE
INHERENTLY IN THE WILD LAND --
PERSPECTIVE AND INSURING THAT WE
ARE DOING WHAT WE NEED TO TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PLANS ARE ARE
ARE IN ORDER -- I HAVE ALSO
BROUGHT WITH ME -- ACTING STATE
FIRE MARSHAL -- MIKE RICH WINE --
TO ASSIST WITH DANCING ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS THAT ARE SPECIFIC
TO WHAT THESE POSITIONS WILL BE
DOING.
THANK YOU ARE THERE LA --
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
PROPOSAL BUT JUST -- FOR
CONTACTS THEY JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE POSITION FOR
REVIEWING THAT WHILE FOR
MEDICATION PLANS.
ARE ONE POSITION AT CAL FIRE
THAT IS -- AND SO THESE TWO
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WOULD BRING
THAT TOTAL TO THREE ON GIVEN THE
WORKLOAD THE NUMBER OF PLANTS
THEY HAVE TO REVIEW THAT SEEMS
REASONABLE -- YOUR STAFF
COMMENTS IN THE AGENDA JUST NOTE
THAT YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
HOW THESE POSITIONS ARE GOING TO
INTERACT WITH POSITIONS AT THE
P. C. FOR DOING SIMILAR TYPE OF
WORK -- FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT
SEEMS REASONABLE THAT CAL FIRE
WOULD HAVE THEIR OWN POSITIONS --
AS WELL SINCE THEY ARE
SPECIFICALLY TASKED WITH CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES UNDER ON SB NINE A
ONE THANK YOU ELEMENT --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING -- DO
YOU WANT TO ADD ANY COMMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO THE ISSUE OF THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE THE
ACOSTA POSITIONS AND PC.
AGAIN I'M GONNA FAST TOO YEAH I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT AS A
RESULT OF THIS BE TEN TWENTY
EIGHT AM SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE'VE HAD A MEMO YOU
WITH -- CPUC AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
THEM ON DEVELOPING THE TEMPLATE.
AND AND IDENTIFYING ISSUES --
RELATIVE TO THE MITIGATION PLANS --
WE HAD A POSITION THAT WAS
LIMITED TERM -- AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR PERMANENT FUNDING
FOR THAT POSITION IN A RESULT OF
THE INCREASE IN IN WORKLOAD.
AND AND THESE SICK.
THE ENORMITY OF THE PLANS --
WE'RE GONNA NEED AN ADDITIONAL
P. WHY IS FOR THAT AS WELL THE
ONE THAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- IS FOUR G. I. S. DATA
COLLECTION FOR US TO SHARE WITH
THE CP UC'S COLLECT DATA FROM
THE P. JEANNIE ENSURE THAT WITH
OUR FIELD FOLKS.
HI THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WHEN WE OPEN UP --
THE PUBLIC HEARING AND ASK IF
THERE IS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME ON ISSUES ONE TWO OR
THREE SEEING NONE -- IS THERE A
MOTION ON WE COULD TAKE -- ISSUE
WANTED TO COLLECTIVELY IF
THERE'S A THEY WISH TO THEM
INDIVIDUALLY JUST IN CASE IT'S
NOT EVERYBODY IS HERE -- IS OUR
MOTION TO APPROVE ISSUE.
ONE THANK YOU INCLUDING
PROVISIONAL AND THANKS FOR
REMINDING ME.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
RAY YES [inaudible]
REVERSE.
AND THAT IS OUR MOTION ON ISSUE
TO ALSO A MOTION TO APPROVE.
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS
PATTERSON I RAY S. [inaudible]
REAR RIVERSIDE.
GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- AS I
MENTIONED ISSUE THREE WILL BE
HOLDING OPEN AND TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
THIS MORNING LIMóN NUMBERS.
NEXT ISSUE IS NUMBER.
FOUR SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY WE HAVE ONE ISSUE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY INCREASE.
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BRING CASH FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY I'M
REPRESENTING THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY TODAY --
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS FOR A
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE AND REIMBURSEMENT FORTY
THE CONSERVANCY RECEIVED A GRANT
FROM.
THE FIRE CAPACITY BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM THAT'S RUN AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION IN
THEIR DIVISION OF LAND RESOURCE
PROTECTION.
AND THIS GRANT WAS AWARDED LAST
MONTH AND WITH THE FUNDING THE
CONSERVANCY WILL DEVELOP A FIRE
PROJECTS AND PRIVATE FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AND I HAVE A BRIGHT IT HERE WITH
ME FROM THE DIVISION OF LAND
RESOURCE PROTECTION IF YOU HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON THE
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
OHIO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE.
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE.
THANK YOU PRETTY EFFICIENT THANK
YOU.
ISSUE FIVE SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER
LA RIVER AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY WE HAVE -- A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE A
POSITION AS A PORTAL -- THE
LOWER LA RIVER RECOMMEND PARK
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION HELLO
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING I HAVE
A LOT TO READ UP AT THE
DESCRIPTION IS I WAS SHORTER
I'LL TRY TO GET.
MY NAME IS SELLING GARCIA I'M A
STAFF SERVICES MANAGER WITH THE
RIVERS AMOUNTS CONSERVANCY.
AND I AM HERE ON THEIR BEHALF TO
HERE -- TO FOR THIS SPRING FOR
THE LETTER -- TO AUTHOR TO
AUTHORIZE ONE ADDITIONAL
POSITION TO OUR AGENCY FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE LOWER LA RIVER RECREATION
AND PARK DISTRICT AS AUTHORIZED
BY SB THIRTY SOMETHING.
FOR OUR INSURE SB THIRTY THREE
FOR AUTHORIZED THE CREATION OF
THE LOWER LA RIVER RECREATION
PARK DISTRICT.
BY PETITION RESOLUTION SUBMITTED
TO THE LAST COKE BEFORE JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE AT THE
ARMS HE WAS CAUGHT UP IN THAT
LEGISLATION -- WE BELIEVE THAT
WE WERE CALLED OUT IN THAT
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF OUR
EFFORTS IN OUR PLANNING AND
DIRECTION WITH AB FIVE THIRTY
THE LOWER LA RIVER REVISE ATION
PLAN.
AND THE OUTCOME OF THAT WAS THE
WORKING GROUP.
SO WITH THIS POSITION -- THEY'LL
BE WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE WORKING GROUP THE RNC AS
WELL AS THE CITIES THAT WERE --
LISTED IN THE LEGISLATION THANK
BECAUSE THE CITY OF BELLE
CUTTING HAY AND PARAMOUNT'S.
THIS POSITION IS JUST FOR THREE
YEARS TO ASSIST IN THE FORMATION
OF THE DISTRICT.
AND AFTER THREE YEARS IT WILL BE
ITS PLAN TO BE ABOLISHED.
AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THANK YOU. FOR THE PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO LA -- PRESENTATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IS NOT ADDING ANY COMMENTS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AND A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD AND
ADDRESSED COMMITTEE ON THIS ITEM?
SEEING NONE WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO APPROVE [inaudible]
BLOOM.
I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON HI RAY
S. REVERSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT MAY ONLY
BE -- AUTHORIZATION FOR ONE
POSITION BUT IT'S NICE TO SEE
THIS PROJECT MOVED INCH BY INCH
PERHAPS DROP BY DROP -- OF
FORWARD IT -- ONE DAY IS GOING
TO BE A REGIONAL RESOURCE THAT --
I I THINK IT'S GONNA SERVE THE
PUBLIC WELL.
OUR LAST ITEM TODAY IS AN
INFORMATION ITEM.
WE WILL BE TAKING A VOTE ON IT
BUT THIS -- INFORMATIONAL ITEM
AS A RESULT OF DISCUSSION DURING
THEIR CAP AND TRADE HEARING THAT
WE HELD A FEW WEEKS AGO AND AT
THAT HEARING I ASKED.
WHY MANY OF THE CATEGORIES
RELATING TO NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS OF HAD NOT BEEN PROPOSED
FOR FUNDING BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE RESPONSE?
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WAS THAT SOME OF THESE
CATEGORIES STILL HAVE FUNDS LEFT
OVER AND OTHERS HAVE OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING AND THE
CONCERN EXPRESSED AT THAT TIME
IS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION MAY
BE FEELING PROP SIXTY EIGHT AS A
WAY. TO SUPPLANT CURRENT SOURCES
OF FUNDING AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT -- OF VOTERS WHO
VOTED FOR PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF
THOSE WHO DID SO DID SO
BELIEVING THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ARE UNDERFUNDED.
AND PROP SIXTY IT WAS MEANT TO
BE ADDITIVE AND NOT REPLACE
pWORD OR GENERAL FUND OF AND IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT VOTERS WOULD NOT
HAVE VOTED FOR THIS IF THEY
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE JUST
REPLACING -- ONE FUND FOR
ANOTHER ONE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
ANOTHER.
SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
INFORMATIONAL I AM TODAY IS FOR
US TO GET.
SOME CLARITY ON THE STATE OF
THESE PROGRAMS -- NAMELY THEIR
DEMAND CURRENT LEVELS OF FUNDING
AND PROPOSED FUNDING AMOUNTS AND
SOURCES.
SHOULD STE ADD THAT WITH --
INCREASED WILDFIRE RISKS AND
INCREASINGLY INTENSE WEATHER
PATTERNS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE ADEQUATELY
FUNDING NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS AND THE INFORMATION -- ARE
FROM THIS HEARING WILL BE --
IMMENSELY HELPFUL TO MYSELF AND
OTHERS AS WE DELIBERATE.
THE BUDGET PROCESS SO I'M SORRY
FOR THE LONG WINDED IN
INTRODUCTION BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
BEING HERE AND SHOWING SOME
ADDITIONAL LIGHT ON THIS ITEM
AND OF COURSE WE'LL TAKE.
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE COMPLETE.
GEN AND BRIAN CASH WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
I'LL BE.
SHARING TESTIMONY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TODAY ON
THIS -- I'LL BE GIVING THE
STATUS OF THE PROGRAMS AND THE
DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAMS --
OVERALL -- I CAN SAY THAT THE
THE PROGRAM THERE'S A LOT OF
DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAMS -- FOR
BOTH THE CAP CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS AND ALSO THE PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
HAVE IS AS MUCH AS FIVE TIMES
THE ASK THAN.
THE ACTUAL FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR BOTH PROP THE GT
R. F. AND PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT THE PROGRAMS ARE ALL
ROLLING FORWARD -- ALL OF THEM
HAVE -- THAT HAVE FUNDING IN
BOTH SIXTY EIGHT IN G. G. R. S.
WILL BE AWARDING THE FUNDS
WITHIN THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
SO -- EVEN THOUGH THEY DO HAVE
PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND G. R. L.
FROM PREVIOUS YEARS THOSE ARE
ALL GOING TO ALL THE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO BE COMMITTED TO
PROJECTS BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO THE THE PROGRAMS ARE ROLLING
AND THE DEMAND IS IS PRETTY HIGH
FOR THEM THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT
DID NOT HAVE HIGH DEMAND WAS --
IN FISH AND WILDLIFE THEIR
WEAPONS PROGRAM.
IN THEIR WORK THEY'RE COMBINING
THEIR MONEY FROM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWO IN DOING AN OUTREACH --
DURING ADDITIONAL OUTRAGE TO
ACTUALLY BRING IN MORE PEOPLE TO
APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM SO THE ONE
THAT DID NOT HAVE -- MORE DEMAND
THAN SUPPLY IS ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING TO GO OUT AND GET MORE
APPLICANTS [inaudible]
GREAT.
CIRCLE AGAR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
SO I DID JUST WANT TO CLARIFY --
THE GENERAL FUND CHART THAT WAS
INCLUDED WITHIN THE AGENDA WHICH
DOES REFERENCE EIGHTY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND DECREASE AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES FUNDING.
HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THAT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AMOUNT REFERENCED IN THE AGENDA
IS THE REVISED EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AMOUNT WHICH INCLUDES THE
INCREASED CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
COST -- IT ALSO INCLUDES A ONE
TIME LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS
THAT WERE APPROVED AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AS A ONE TIME BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND ALSO
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENT THAT WAS MADE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CENTER.
SO ABSENT THE INCREASED
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES COST FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND ABSENT THE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT THERE IS A
GENERAL FUND INCREASE IN
INVESTMENT IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES PROGRAM.
WHICH WE WANT TO CLARIFY -- THAT
NO ON ON THAT CHART.
AND ALSO JUST TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT ON THE
OVERALL BUDGET FRAMEWORK -- THE
BUDGET DOES FOCUS ON RESILIENCY
AT THE THING ABILITY AND WHILE
THE STATE DOES CURRENTLY HAVE A
STRONG FOUNDATION AND A HEALTHY
BUDGET THERE IS CONTINUE TO
GROWING RISK AND UNCERTAINTY --
AND WHILE WE ARE ASSUMING.
MODERATE GROWTH OVER TO THE
FORECAST PERIOD I EVEN A MATER
RECESSION COULD HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
STATE'S THE GENERAL FUND REVENUE
SO MAINTAINING THE STATE'S
FISCAL HEALTH AND AND THE STATE
BUDGET.
IS CRITICAL AND IT'S STILL ON
ONGOING CHALLENGE GIVEN THE BALL
TH<c.cyan> REVENUE BASE AND THE</c>
LIMITED -- SPENDING FLEXIBILITY
AND YOU MAY RECALL IN THE LAST
RECESSION THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
CUTS TO THE STATE PARKS AND
OTHER RESOURCES PROGRAMS SO THE
FOCUS ON BUDGET RESILIENCY AND
BUDGETS THE THING ABILITY.
MAY HELP US PRESERVE SOME OF
THESE -- NATURAL RESOURCES
PROGRAMS IF THE NEXT ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN HAPPENS.
WELL -- WHAT OTHER AREAS OF THE
BUDGET ARE -- ARE ARE BEING
CONSIDEREDTHE WAY THIS YEAR THE
BUDGET AS I MEAN I TAKE YOUR
POINT.
THAT WE WANT -- TO PRESERVERS
ALIENS IN THE BUDGET AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT WERE -- BEING
RESPONSIBLE CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL NEXT RECESSION --
BUT THIS LITTLE PIECE OF THE OF
THE BUDGET SEEMS TO STAND OUT --
AND IT IN SO FAR AS THE A LACK
OF FOR A OF OF FUNDING SO.
IF THIS IS.
A IS IS THE ONLY AREA THAT --
THIS BEING TREATED THAT WAY OR
IS THERE SOME RHYME OR REASON
AND OTHER AREAS -- THAT THE SAME
LOGIC IS BEING APPLIED.
SO IF THEY IF IF IF BUDGET
FRAMEWORK APPLIES TO ALL AREAS --
AND LOOKING AT NATURAL RESOURCES
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS THERE
HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
GENERAL FUND INCREASES FOR AND
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION AND NINE
TEN TO NOW THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION.
AND THAT IN ADDITION TO THE BOND
FUNDS WHICH ARE ULTIMATELY THAT
SERVICE PAID BY THE GENERAL FUND
IN ADDITION TO THE SPECIAL FUNDS
SO.
IF WE LOOK AT HISTORICAL GROWTH
IN THIS AREA THEY HAVE BEEN
CLIMBING OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
AGO THAT SO HAVE -- VIRTUALLY
EVERY OTHER AREA OF THE BUDGET
SO WHAT DISTINGUISHES THIS FROM
ALL THOSE OTHER AREAS.
I WILL BE.
SURE TO READ THE COVER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- I THINK.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE CHART
IN THE AGENDA AND TRYING TO LOOK
AT LIKE THE YEAR OVER YEAR
CHANGES I THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF UNUSUAL THINGS THAT
MISTER AGUILAR IS REFERRING TO
LIKE?
THE THAT EMERGENCY RESPONSE
MONEY THAT WAS IN HERE THE ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS ARE NOT UNIQUE
TO THIS AREA I THINK THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF AREAS OF HAD
ONE TIME I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN PART OF
PRIOR BUDGETS.
AND SO I THINK -- TRAINING
OVERTIME IS.
SERGIO MENTIONED IT HAS BEEN
GROWING AND WE WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT KIND OF LOOKING AT THIS
YEAR OVER YEAR.
I AM AT WITH THE REVISED NUMBERS
DOESN'T QUITE QUITE REFLECT ALL
THE OTHER THINGS GOING ON IN
THIS AREA.
WITH THE THE BOND FUNDS WITH THE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT WITH THE
EMERGENCY FUNDING THAT WAS IN
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
DID YOU HAVE MORE THAT YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THEM I'VE ALSO AND I
ALSO WANTED TO JUMP IN THE
MIDDLE NO NO NO THAT IS LIFE AND
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO QUESTIONS
AND ONE OF THE THINGS YEAH I
WOULD.
YOU SEE THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
IN THE AGENDA WE WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR RESPONSES TO THE GREAT
THANK YOU.
AND ON THAT CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLANNED SO -- NOTING
THAT I THINK GOING BACK TO AT MY
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WENT INTO
THE JANUARY TURN TEN VERSION OF
THE CAP AND MAKE SENATOR KEVIN
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN -- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE HAD
MORE REVENUES IN THE PLAN AND SO
WE HAVE DROPPED FROM THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS TO
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN EXPENDITURE
PLANET JANUARY.
TEN CONSIDERATIONS THAT WERE --
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT INCLUDE YOU
KNOW THE DECLINING REVENUE
LEVELS -- THE GOALS OF MEETING
THE REQUIRED 35% TARGETS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS LOOKING AT THE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
RECEIVE FUNDING ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
AND ALSO -- LOOKING AND
RESPONDING TO THE FEEDBACK THAT
WAS PROVIDED AS PART.
OF THE THIRD INVESTMENT PLAN
FROM STAKEHOLDERS THE FOCUS ON
THE LOOKING AT LOCAL NEEDS --
YOU KNOW.
PART OF THE FUNDING GOING TO
THAT TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS SUCH AS THOSE SO
WE JUST WANTED TO GIVE A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT OF WHAT WENT INTO
THE JANUARY.
TEN PLANNING AS WELL AS THE
DECLINING CAP AND TRADE REVENUES.
THE QUESTION ALSO POSED IN THE
AGENDA IS ASKING WHETHER WE ARE
CONSIDERING RESTORATION AS PART
OF THE MAYOR VISION AND I'M
OBVIOUSLY NOT AT LIBERTY TO
DISCUSS WHAT'S IN THE MAY
REVISION BUT WE WILL HAVE -- AN
UPDATED PLAN BECAUSE OF UPDATED
REVENUES AS IS.
TYPICALLY WHAT WE PROVIDE IT MAY
REVISION.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THE VOTERS
WERE LOOKING FOR WHEN THEY
PASSED PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT SO ON I AND M..
I HAVE A AS USUAL I MEAN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
RIGHT AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS IS
BEEN -- A TOPIC THAT'S BEEN AND
COVER BEFORE AND DISCUSSED
BEFORE US AS FAR AS WHERE TO
INVEST AS PROP SIXTY EIGHT
DOLLARS -- WANTED A NOTE THAT.
THE EXISTENCE OF THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT DOLLARS ALONE DOESN'T.
PRECLUDE ADDITIONAL JDRF
SPENDING I THINK HEALTHY SOILS
IS ONE AREA WHERE THEY HAD PROP
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING I BELIEVE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND IS
ACTUALLY EXPANDED UPON IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THIS OVER
ARCHING RULE THAT IS APPLIED AS
FAR AS WHAT'S THERE FOR PROP
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING.
I AGREE WITH WHAT MR CASH
PRESENTED AS FAR AS THEIR SCENES
YOU KNOW TO BE QUITE A DEMAND
FOR THE PROP SIXTY PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS A CAP AND TRADE PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS JUST THE GENERAL FUND.
OVERALL AND SO I THINK TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION KIND OF ALL
THE FUNDING SOURCES THAT COME
INTO PLAY IN THIS AREA IT IS --
ONE THAT INVOLVES ALL OF YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT ALL THE NEEDS
AND THEN PRIORITIZING BASED ON
WHAT REVENUES ARE AVAILABLE AND
FOR WHAT PURPOSES CHAU -- I
WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S VIEW ON
THIS DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
VIEW -- PROXY PROP SIXTY EIGHT
AS A FUNDING SOURCE THAT SUB
THAT WOULD BE SUPPLEMENTAL -- TO
THESE PROGRAMS OR THAT WOULD
SUPPLANT THE I THINK OUR VIEW IS
WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
ALL THE FUNDING STREAMS KIND OF
AS I PREVIOUSLY NOTED SO WE HAVE
PROP SIXTY EIGHT FUNDED PROGRAMS --
GENERAL FUND FUNDED PROGRAMS CAP
AND TRADE FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
JUST TAKING A LOOK AT ALL OF
THOSE [inaudible]
RIGHT I'M.
NOT SATISFIED WITH THAT RESPONSE --
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THEN WHY DON'T WE I TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO HEAR FROM --
THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO SPEAK TO
THIS ISSUE FROM THE PUBLIC.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF FEDERAL KNOWN
BEHALF OF VINYL TO SPENT.
SKEWS ME.
WE HAVE A FINAL DEFENCE FUND --
WE'VE BEEN REALLY ENCOURAGED BY
THE DISCUSSION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENGAGED IN ON
BOTH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
PRODUCTION FUND --
PRIORITIZATION FOR NATIONAL
WRITTEN PLANS AS WELL AS THAT OF
THE BROADER DISCUSSION ABOUT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS FROM
GENERAL FUND.
AGREED THAT AND YOU KNOW THERE
WERE A LOT OF ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS AND SO HOPEFULLY
THAT OPENS THE DOOR FOR
ADDITIONAL -- CONSIDERATION OF
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS IN
NETWORKING LINES EVEN FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IN ADDITION TO
WHAT'S BEING DISCUSSED --
ESPECIALLY ENCOURAGED BY THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A JOINT LETTER
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS
THAT SIGNED ON EARLY ON IN THE
YEAR -- PRIORITIZING THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- OF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND --
AND NOW WHAT'S BEING SHARED IS A
SIGN ON LETTER WITH OVER NINETY
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS FROM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA -- REALLY
EXPRESSING -- INCREASE SUPPORT
FOR THAT PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
BEGINNING TO TO LOOK AT HOW THAT
THOSE FUNDING -- AMOUNTS COULD
ACTUALLY BE BROKEN UP UP BY THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED -- THE LAST
THING I WOULD ADD TO IS -- YOU
KNOW REALLY ENCOURAGED TO HEAR
THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE ABLE TO
METABOLIZE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE -- IN
PARTICULAR LOOKING AT A LOT OF
THE UPCOMING ISSUES THAT WE ARE
OUR STATE IS GONNA BE FACING
WHETHER IT'S COASTAL OR INLAND
COMMUNITIES.
RURAL URBAN COMMUNITIES ON THE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
OUTLINED IN THIS LETTER --
BENEFITS ALL CALIFORNIA --
WHETHER YOU TALK ABOUT SEA LEVEL
RISE URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT IN
URBAN COMMUNITIES IN THE WAYS IN
WHICH URBAN GREETING IN URBAN
FORESTRY CAN CAN HELP WITH THAT --
DEALING WITH COASTAL ADAPTATION
DEALING WITH FOREST HEALTH
MANAGEMENT ALL THE ABOVE SO WE
DO FEEL THAT YES IT IS IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN A FISCAL PRUDENCE
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
INVESTMENTS WITH A NEED TO BE
MADE.
TODAY SO THAT WE CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE DIVIDENDS OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS YOU KNOW FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS DOWN THE LINE WHEN
WE ALL KNOW THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS GOING TO EXACERBATE A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES -- AND REALLY HAVE.
DRASTIC IMPACTS ON THE ABILITY
OF OF OUR STATE TO MAINTAIN
RESILIENCY SO THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS THE SILENCE
SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND I THANK THE
CHAIR FOR OFFERING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WE HAVE BROUGHT UP
MANY TIMES IN COMMITTEE THAT WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE INTENT OF PROP SIXTY EIGHT
BEING ADDITIVE IN NOT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN NATURE SO WE WE
REALLY DO HAVE THAT CONCERN AND
WE WOULD CONTINUE -- TO TO VOICE
SITTING COMMITTEE SO PERHAPS A
DIGITAL CLARITY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
VIEWPOINT ON HOW THOSE FUNDS
INTEND TO BE SPENT WOULD BE
HELPFUL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING QUALITY MEAT ON A
WITHOUT A ONE CALIFORNIA -- WE
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO OUR LINE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS ARE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK THAT.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CLARITY AND I CERTAINLY CHAIR
THE CHAIRS.
POINT OF VIEW THAT THE ANSWERED
THE ADMINISTRATION GAVE ON PROP
SIXTY EIGHT TO ADD.
EVERYTHING ELSE I DON'T THINK
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW
SATISFACTORY EITHER WE'VE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION BOTH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE INVESTING IN OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE NEED TO BE PAYING.
AND INVESTING.
MONEY INTO INTO THIS -- SECTOR
WITH.
YELP LOOK QUITE FRANKLY LESS
EXPENSIVE MONEY THAN BOND
DOLLARS AND WE TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN.
ACHIEVE THAT ARE ON THE ISSUE OF
THE OF THE DFW DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE'S.
ISSUE REGARDING -- UNDER
SUBSCRIBER -- WETLANDS -- ISSUES --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WANT.
TO ENCOURAGE NOT ONLY THIS
COMMITTEE.
EXPANDTHAT -- THOSE FUNDS
BEYOND JUST COASTAL WETLANDS
INCLUDE.
CENTRAL VALLEY WEAPONS AS WELL
HEY WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY THERE ISN'T
AS MUCH AS OVER SUBSCRIPTION TO
THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO SEE SOME
OF THOSE INVESTMENTS THEY ARE
AND WE BELIEVE IN NOT A NUMBER
OF CENTRAL OUT COMMUNITIES.
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANALLY ZERO
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO LINE OURSELVES
WITH ON ONE COMMENTS AS WELL AND
SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHT THE
WETLAND RESTORATION PROGRAM AS
WELL WE'VE LOST OVER 90% OF
CALIFORNIA'S WETLANDS.
ALREADY AND THE STATE WATER
BOARD JUST ENACTED NEW RULES TO
PROTECT WETLANDS FROM JUDGE
UNTIL ACTIVITIES BUT EVEN THEIR
OWN ANALYSIS SHOWED THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE A NET LOSS OF
WETLANDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHEN WE WENT TO BAT FOR PROP
SIXTY EIGHT IT WAS CERTAINLY
UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT THE
MONEY WOULD BE ADDITIVE AND AND
NOT SUPPLANT THE G. DRIVE MONEY
SO WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HAPPEN THANK YOU.
HI AM IDEAL WITH CALIFORNIA
RELIEF I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
THE COMEDIANS CONSULTANTS. FOR
INCLUDING THIS TOPIC IMPORTANT
TOPIC -- AND IT'S CAUSING IT ON
AN OPEN FORUM -- I WANT TO LIE
MY COMMENTS -- WITH AUDUBON AND
I'M MEDIA IF AND DEFENDERS -- I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE BOND
MONEY THAT WAS ALLOCATED FOR
URBAN FORESTRY WILL BE INCUMBENT
BEFORE IT JANUARY FIRST SO THERE
IS NO FUNDS.
FROM PROP -- SIXTY EIGHT FOR
URBAN FORESTRY -- AND THEN
[inaudible]
SEE -- AND THE KIDS ARE WEARING
FOR STREET MULTIPLE.
MINISTRY -- TO THIS IS TOO HIGH.
OF YEAH THERE MULTIPLE -- STRAPS
AND FINAL REPORTS SUCH AS THE
FINAL CAR IN PLANTS THAT SAYS
THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE OUR
URBAN TREE CANOPY BY 10% BUT
THERE'S NO MONEY FUNDED.
THERE'S NO FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR
THAT THE EIGHTY URBAN FOR SHE
NEVER GREEN PROGRAM.
FOR THROUGH THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET -- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION -- SO I URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO CONTINUE ITS
LEADERSHIP AND INVESTING IN
URBAN FORESTRY INCLUDING
INVESTMENTS TO COMBAT.
THE STRONGHOLD FOR ISSUE --
SUPPORT CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS THAT -- HELP BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN IN.
COMMITTEES.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG SOUP ON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY AND OUR ORGANIZATION IS.
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR NATURAL
WORKING LANCE -- THIS IS ALL
ABOUT [inaudible]
TAKING BOLD.
NEW STEPS TO REDUCE.
CARBON.
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE SEQUESTER
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE HE'S
OUR NEW THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING --
AND WERE LEADING THE NATION IN
HOW WE DO IT AND IT'S GOING TO
COST. TO DO IT IT'S AN
APPROPRIATION THAT IS NECESSARY.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH --
TAKING THESE NEW INITIATIVES.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT.
OUR ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
PLANS A SITE IS A PLAN
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION AND A
LOT OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS MOVING PLANTS AROUND ON THE
LANDSCAPE -- WHILE WE DO THAT WE
SEE THE NEED FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING STILL. TO SUPPORT THE
THE BUYER DIVERSITY INITIATIVE
CALIFORNIA'S BIODIVERSITY
INITIATIVE -- TO DEVELOP NEW
TOOLS AND TO BACK UP.
OUR SEEDBANK OF A FOR PLANT
BIODIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA SO --
WE'RE WE SUPPORT ALSO ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR YOU SEE BANKING.
AND FOR DEVELOPING IMPORTANT NEW
TOOLS LIKE CONSERVATION GENOMICS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS ATTENTION HI
MY NAME IS LINDA COMMISSION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF TRANSFORM.
TO SUPPORT -- CONTINUED AT A
INVESTMENTS IN URBAN GREENING
URBAN FORESTRY AND ALSO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE ALREADY AT THESE
PROGRAMS.
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
FOR THE CO BENEFITS THAT COME TO
MAKING COMMUNITIES BY COUPLE
WALKABLE A TRANSIT FRIENDLY
PLACES IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE.
THAT TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT SO THAT
IT'S COMFORTABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
GET OTHER CARS AND AND MAKE THE
TRIPS THAT THEY NEED TO EVERY
DAY -- BY WALKING BIKING THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTEO CROWN
BEHALF THE MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION UTHORITY AND SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPENS THIS
AUTHORITY -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR A CONTINUING TO PUSH
ON THIS ISSUE -- THIS IS WE
DON'T SEE PROP -- SIXTY EIGHT
INTEGER ATHLETES IN THIS
COMPLEMENTARY ITEMS -- AND WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS SORT OF
SAN PLANTATION ONS WE CONTINUE
TO A SUPPORT YOUR PUSH ON THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE --
WE ALSO WANT TO REITERATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ASK FOR NATURISTS
HORSES INVESTMENT -- FROM GRF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE GERMAN BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
MASON FOR PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
AND WE WERE MUCH APPRECIATE THE
TEARS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AS WELL.
FREE WITH THE POOREST REST
AGREED WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN SAID SO FAR AND I WANT TO
STEP BACK AND JUST LOOK AT THE
BIG PICTURE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALL VERY COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS FOR US TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
BUT THE PLACE WHERE I THINK THEY
REALLY ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
IS HELPING TO ADAPT OUR NATURAL
LANDSCAPE TO THE WORLD WE'RE
GOING TO BE LIVING AND AND UNDER
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT'S WHERE I AM MOST FREAKED
OUT BY THE LACK OF PROGRESS THE
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS A BIGGER STORMS
BIGGER FLOODS.
THE SORTS OF INVESTMENTS WE SEE
AND RESTORING MOUNTAIN MEADOWS
AND FORESTS AND WATERSHED.
CAN BE CRITICAL FOR BUFFERING
THAT STORM FLOW AND HELPING TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T SEE ANOTHER
SITUATION.
LIKE WITH IN ORVILLE COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO YOU KNOW THE HOT DRY
SUMMERS THEY'RE GONNA BE DEALING
WITH THE URBAN FORESTRY URBAN
GREENING INVESTMENT OR MAKING A
MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
HABITABILITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
FUTURE.
BUT THESE THINGS TAKE TIME TO
COME TO FRUITION THE STREET OR
PLANTING THIS YEAR AND NEXT YEAR
ARE GONNA BE GREAT SHADE TREES
RATHER DECADE OR TWO SO WE CAN'T
BE PUTTING THE THINGS OFF WE
NEED TO BE MAKING.
THESE SUBSTANTIVE INVESTMENTS
NOW SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
CAN TUNE TO PUSH THE ISSUE AND I
HOPE THE ADMINISTRATION AUGMENTS
THE MAY REVISE WE SEE THAT A
COUPLE WEEKS THANK YOU.
GENERAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMB IT AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK --
I WANTED LINE MY COMMENTS WITH A
POEM MASONS FROM PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST.
WE WORK WITH FARMERS -- AROUND
THE STATE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
THE CLAIM IT'S MORE LIKE A
CULTURE PROGRAMS QUITE FRANKLY
NOT ALWAYS BECAUSE THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN REDUCING METHANE
EMISSIONS ARE NECESSARILY
SEQUESTERING CARBON.
BUT THOSE SAME PROJECTS THAT ARE
DELIVERING THOSE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION BENEFITS ARE
DELIVERING BENEFITS TO THE FARM --%
BUT WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN
THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
CLAIM IS MORE AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS WHETHER IT'S HEALTHY
SOILS FOR THE STATE WATER
EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
OR WITH THE ALTERNATE BEEN OUR
MANTRA PROGRAM.
IS THAT FUNDING NUMBERS GO UP
AND DOWN SOME YEARS ARE CUTTING
TIRE LEASE SOME YEARS WE HAVE
BOND -- MONEY SOME YEARS WE
DON'T -- THE REQUIREMENTS CHANGE
WHETHER IT'S TO EUROPE FOR BOND
FUNDS AND IT'S BEEN QUITE
CHALLENGING TO BUILD MOMENTUM ON
THE GROUND AND BRING MORE
FARMERS -- INTO THESE PROGRAMS --
BECAUSE THE RULES KEEP CHANGING
THE FUNDING SOURCES KEEP
CHANGING SOME YEARS WE HAVE
FUNDING SOME YEARS WE DON'T --
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS WITH OUT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
NATURAL WORKING LAND STRATEGIES
CLIMATE SMART UYGHUR CULTURE IS
A KEY COMPONENT TO THAT.
IT'S MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN KEY
AGRICULTURAL AREAS IN THE STATE
AND ALSO MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR
A LONG TERM FOOD SECURITY SIR
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS AND FOCUS
TODAY.
ON THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT ISSUE
IT'S A CRITICAL DISCUSSION
AROUND WHAT IS OUR LONG TERM
STRATEGY FOR INVESTING IN
NATURAL WORKING LANDS CLIMATE
CHANGE STRATEGIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- YES MS
RIVER.
THANK YOU -- I WANTED TO COMMENT
ON YOU KNOW SOME CONCERNS I HAVE --
PARTICULAR WITH.
THAT WERE SUPPLANTING ON CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING FOR THE WITH URBAN
GREEN IN -- YOU KNOW AND LIKE
RAIMES FROM IN LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE ONE POINT EIGHT PARKS PER
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I'M A YOU KNOW WE'RE PARK
DEFICIENT AREA YOU KNOW KIDS
DON'T HAVE.
ACCESS TO GREEN SPACES NEAR
THEIR HOMES -- YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE SHOOTING BE
INCREASING GREEN SPACES AND NOT.
ON DECREASING THEM ESPECIALLY
OUR INVESTMENTS IN THOSE AREAS
IN HERE THAT'S ONE THE REASONS
I'VE AUTHORED AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU KNOW TO CREATE --
GREEN SPACES AND SCHOOLS IN A
LOT OF KIDS -- ART SCHOOL DAY
THIS IS THEIR ONLY ACCESS -- TO
A POTENTIAL GREEN SPACE -- YOU
KNOW UNLESS -- YOU KNOW WE
CREATE MORE THAN -- THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THEIR IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW SO -- I
THINK WE SHOULD BE USING BOTH
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH THE G. G.
pINCREASE GREEN SPACES ESPECIALLY
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
PROVIDING US.
WITH INFORMATION TODAY ON ON ON
THIS ITEM -- AS I'M SURE YOU
KNOW I'M A BIT FRUSTRATED -- BY
WHAT WE'RE HEARING I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR -- THAT -- VOTERS
SPOKE IN FAVOR OF PROVIDING --
MORE REVENUE -- NOT TO THE
EVENING OUT THE BUDGET OR
UTILIZING -- THESE PRECIOUS
FUNDS -- FOR FOR OTHER PURPOSES --
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW I THINK
IT'S JUST BACKED UP BY LOGIC AS
MUCH AS ANYTHING ELSE THESE --
THE VOTERS VOTED TO SUPPLEMENT
OUR FUNDING -- THIS IS -- THE
THE ISSUES THAT -- PROP SIXTY
EIGHT ARE.
INTENDED TO ADDRESS ARE OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE -- TO A TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS BUT
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE TWO TO
THOSE.
WHO CARED ENOUGH TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE AND -- TO INCREASE
REVENUE SOURCES SAY A THING VERY
CAREFULLY AS WE ALL KNOW ABOUT --
ABOUT THESE ISSUES SO WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY -- TO TO ALLOCATE
THE FUNDS IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY
THAT REFLECTS THE THE OF USE OF
THE OF THE VOTERS AND I DON'T
THINK THAT -- THE CURRENT
EXPENDITURE PLAN -- FOR THESE
FUNDS -- REFLECTS THAT SO I'M
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE MAY REVISE AND HOPING
THAT -- WE WE WILL SEE --
MARKEDLY DIFFERENT APPROACH.
THERE'S NO FURTHER COMMENT SENT
WILLA DISMISS YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR FOR BEING HERE TODAY WE DO
HAVE THAT ON VOTES AND TO TAKEN
BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO JUST --
POINT OUT THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED
BY A NUMBER OF ADVOCATES AND
MEMBERS TO KEEP VARIOUS BCP'S
OPEN BECAUSE OF PENDING REQUESTS
TO AUGMENT THOSE PROPOSALS AND I
WANT TO CLARIFY -- THAT ACTION
ON THOSE BCP'S WILL NOT UNDERCUT
THE ABILITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
TO PROVIDE THOSE REQUIRED
AUGMENTATIONS -- SO I'M HOPING
THAT THAT CLARIFIES -- OF THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE FOR FOLKS WHO
MIGHT BE CONCERNED AND TO WITH
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OUR AT ON
BOATS.
OF VOTE ONLY ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
WAS PULLED ON VOTE ONLY.
ISSUES TWO THREE FIVE SEVEN
THROUGH TEN TWELVE THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- CHAIR VOTING I
CURRENT VOTE. FOUR ZERO AFTER
MEMBERS FONG [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES ONE SIX FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FONG
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES FOR FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FONG
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
CHAIR VOTING AYE [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IT -- SORRY -- THERE ARE.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET WITH PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FIVE ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS MULLIN
[inaudible]
RADIUS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO STATE THE VOTE ON OH SORRY
AS VOTE IS.
SEVEN ZERO ITEMS TO BE HEARD
ISSUE NUMBER TWO CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY S..
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO THE ITEM IS
OUT.
THANK YOU EVERYONE THAT BRING
ARTS TO MORE ITEMS.
PHONE.
AND IN A WAY THAT I DON'T SEE
HEARD ISSUE NUMBER FOUR CURRENT
VOTE IS.
FIVE ZERO CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS MULLIN [inaudible]
REYES.
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO ITEM IS OUT.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST -- ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY YES.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF THE MEETING WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL